yesterday I told you that in the wake of
the parkland Florida school shooting
Dick's Sporting Goods was going to raise
its gun buying age to 21 they were or
are going to remove assault style rifles
from its stores and they're also getting
rid of high-capacity magazines it's a
great change although like I said
yesterday they're not doing it at their
sister store Field & Stream which I
actually think is more sort of like the
gun enthusiast store but ok it's a
change and they're making it and I think
it's the right change Walmart now is
also going to be making changes to its
gun sales policy they are going to stop
selling guns and ammunition to people
under age 21
they already you might recall that back
in 2015 Walmart stopped selling certain
rifles including the ar-15 in its stores
and it's also going to be removing kids
toys that resemble assault style rifles
from its website ok that one seems more
like a PR one than any one that's going
to be sort of practically applicable but
ok Walmart put out a statement about
this they said it is because of the
recent events meaning the parkland
Florida shooting I actually think that
there's something else at play here it's
because of the outcry as a result of the
recent events there have been school
shootings before and stores like Dick's
and Walmart don't always change their
policy this is not because of the event
this is because of the activism
that has been triggered by the event in
parkland Florida including by kids and
we may not get comprehensive background
checks Florida might well decide that
they're going to arm teachers but I
would argue that already the activism
that we've seen after the shooting has
catalyzed more change on guns than we've
seen in a long time a lot of it from the
private sector right companies making
changes to policy and yeah like I said
yesterday a lot of these changes are for
PR they are calculated business
decisions more than moral decisions that
doesn't mean that they're the wrong
decisions and as a result I still
support it now that's the good of it
right it's not all
waterfalls and sunshine and ginger snaps
the truth is that in many places
Walmart really doesn't sell that many
guns online there were Walmart employees
noting that in 2018 in their particular
store that they work in only like a
handful of firearms have been sold it's
still a good thing that Walmart is doing
this but the truth is that a lot of
these places Dick's and Walmart are not
like the go-to s for firearms and that
Wal Mart and Dick's doing this isn't
gonna reduce the demand for these
firearms and if anything could be the
opposite we know that when people become
worried that they're not going to be
able to get a certain type of gun they
go out and buy it and actually these
headlines even though I believe that
it's the right policy at the micro level
at the macro level it could create a run
on these guns from your local gun stores
we know that under President Obama the
constant fear mongering from the write
about Obama coming to take your guns
actually led to record gun sales and of
course Obama never took anybody's guns
and of course not to be repetitive even
though these assault style rifles are
commonly used in the mass shootings that
we see most gun deaths are single or
double homicides that get very little
media attention and they're committed
with handguns which no one is talking
about paring down sales of it all
I'd have to imagine that most gun sales
happen at the small locally owned places
that's a heck of any big chain like an
ammo czar us out there now and so those
small locally owned places don't really
have to deal with PR as much as these
retail giants know down so is there
really an incentive for them to raise
the age from 18 to 21 now probably not
so I don't think this is gonna make a
big difference in the net no and it's
particularly not going to make a big
difference look and I want to be careful
how I say this every mass shooting is a
major tragedy right when when 12 people
died in a mass shooting that is 12 times
the death that we see in a single
homicide however just to give you a
sense of the numbers since the parkland
Florida shooting which was 15 days ago
right February 14th was the parkland
Florida shooting which killed 17 people
and injured I believe it was 15 in the
time that has elapsed since the Parkland
'lord a shooting 495 people have been
killed by guns and another 85 have to
have been injured right since 17 died in
parkland Florida at the hands of an
assault rifle 495 people were killed
mostly by handguns most of the incidents
were one or two people who died a
handful of incidents had three or four
people that were that were shot dead so
the decision by Dickson Walmart is a
good decision
I support the decision but I do believe
that this is not going to decrease gun
sales in the net I think it's probably
going to increase them and I don't
believe that it deals with the broader
problems which are far-reaching as I've
talked about many times cultural
background checks mental health
availability etc etc and by the way on
the age 21 thing for the most part the
shootings aren't being done by people
under age 21 anyway right I agree that
you shouldn't be able to buy a gun if
you're under 21 but mostly it's people
older than 21 that are committing these
horrible acts I am not criticizing the
decisions I am NOT saying that they are
bad decisions what I'm saying is this is
very very complex and multifaceted and
this is the tiniest part of the problems
at hand we talked about making a change
in the government level yeah I don't
think there would be anything
unconstitutional about changing the age
from 18 to 21 no I mean if you remember
for the longest time the voting age was
21 until like the 1970s yep so I think
they could get away with that without
any second amendment issues yeah well
they could get away with it without any
get away with it without any actual
second amendment issues no but of course
you would see the Second Amendment
fetishists absolutely lose there you
know what if this was attempted so
anyway that that those are my thoughts
there and we'll see if other big
companies come out and make similar
changes today's episode of the show is
made possible in part by brilliant which
is really an amazing website that lets
you engage in fun and interesting
problems and puzzles to learn more about
really important stuff math science
engineering the community aspect of
brilliant is great there's over five
million members there bringing together
the knowledge and experience of their
students their educators the
professionals around the world that
develop a lot of the hands-on learning
problems that you will
work through and learning with a
community makes a huge difference right
when you use brilliant you're part of
that 5 million member community they
share your curiosity and love for math
and science and the community at
brilliant also supports your learning
because you build a connection with the
subjects you're learning by interacting
with other people studying the same
material you can get started right now
by signing up for free at brilliant org
slash David Pakman first 200 people who
visit brilliant org slash David Pakman
will get 20% off an annual premium
membership that is brilliant org forward
slash David Pakman support us by
supporting brilliant